my name is Lee Ching lo I am a professor
of biology at Stanford University and I
investigate of the Howard Hughes Medical
Institute in my lab I lead research in
studying how neural circuits are
assembled during development
and how they process information in
adults
and also I teach to Stanford
undergraduate students and graduate
students neurobiology
I grew up in Shanghai China my first 10
years coincide with the cultural
revolution
in in China so at that time there was no
real studies
and my childhood dream was to become a
bus driver in Shanghai
and then lucky for me at when I was 10
Cultural Revolution was over so there
was a big emphasis on promoting science
and Science Education and that got me
interested in science when I was a
middle school student I left Shanghai at
the age of 15 to study in college in
University of Science and Technology of
China
and then after I get my bachelor degree
I came to United States
to attend Brandeis University to get my
PhD Brandeis is a small but excellent
University a subset of disciplines and
the Neuroscience happened to be their
strongest
one of the strongest disciplines so I
became interested in Neuroscience
because of that and in retrospect it was
a lucky accident because Neuroscience
there's just so many unexplored
interesting questions and following that
I at postdoctoral research at the
University of California San Francisco
before I started my own lab and become a
faculty member at Stanford University
I would say that the most fun part of my
work is really to work together with
very talented
trainees students and postdocs who are
working passionately and work very
diligently to solve
mysteries of nature when I started my
faculty position at Stanford I was
teaching a neurobiology class to
undergraduate students graduate students
and at a time Richard Axel and Linda
Buck just figured out the mechanism of
how olfactory information flows from the
nose to the brain and for which they got
a Nobel Prize and I told students that
actually exactly how neurons from the
nose
connect with neurons to the brain we
know very little about
and then about a year or two later we
developed a new technology to address
this kind of questions and now
dozens of papers
later and 20 some years later we are
still using the fly olfactory system to
explore fundamental questions of how
neural circuits are assembled during
development we know a lot about
individual sensory systems Vision or
faction
Etc how they each work but by comparison
how different sensory systems
work together to give us an integrated
picture of the world we know really very
little about that's why I emphasize in
the Frontiers section about integration
of multi-sensory systems with the hope
that I my writing can Inspire subset of
students to choose those topics to for
their career of research
thank you